This video is brought to you by magic spoon.
What's up wisecrack Michael here today.
We're talking about one of our all-time favorite shows and how that show screwed
up a bit. Nothing too touchy, right?
Jay's had somebody a little out Archer quickly became one of our most beloved
shows, thanks to its quickfire.
Banter. You know how bad that is for your eardrums. I said, do you know,
drive the car, wonderfully psychotic characters.
Shall we.
And die hard commitment to chaos and fear.
I only have porn just laying around.
Popularity is a bit of a double-edged sword for a TV series. Higher ratings,
create more pressure for the show to run and run,
making it harder and harder for the writers to pump out top tier television that
doesn't get boring and some shows crumble under.
This. Wait, you know what you need flash.
To its credit.
Archer has been pretty fearless and its attempts to solve this problem,
but still something went wrong.
Rest assured we're not going on some anti Archer tirade.
We respect that the show completely overhauled itself on numerous occasions in
increasingly bold ways. But weirdly the more Archer changed,
the more it kind of stayed the same. And usually for the worse.
Splenda, introspection is the enemy of happiness.
So my advice is don't always work for me. Has it though?
I don't know. That's the beauty.
No, really. And we'll explain why in this wisecrack edition on Archer,
what went wrong and spoilers.
For Archer ahead.
But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor the product that has fueled
today's video magic spoon cereal. When I was a kid,
I used to love eating cereal, but I had to give it up because as I got older,
it started to make me feel awful.
It tasted like pure sugar and would always leave me feeling sick.
Not exactly how you want to start your day.
Magic's food is a cereal for us olds that aren't yet Facebook commenters,
but also aren't hopping on the latest tic-tac trend. It comes in four flavors,
Coco, fruity, frosted, and blueberry. And with the variety pack,
you can try them all. It tastes amazing. And I love it. It has no sugar,
11 grams of protein and only three net grams of carbs in each serving it's
keto friendly. Gluten-free grain-free soy-free low carb and GMO free,
which basically means you'll actually feel good after eating it.
If you don't believe me, then you have to try it out for yourself.
Click the link in the description to grab a variety pack today when you're
there,
use the promo code wisecrack@checkouttogetfreeshippingorgotomagicspoon.com
slash wisecrack magic spoon is so confident in their cereal.
It's backed with a 100% happiness guarantee.
So if you don't like it for any reason, they'll refund your money.
No questions asked.
So click the link below and use the code wisecrack for free shipping or go to
magic spoon.com/wisecrack.
Now back to the show to figure what went wrong.
We have to figure out what went right by Adam Reed's own admission.
Archer is essentially a workplace comedy.
Even if it doesn't look like when at first glance,
whether they're stealing diamonds or selling cocaine,
the members of ISIS are always steeped in office drama.
There are workplaces defined by gossip, grudges and petty rivalries.
Also flex accounts.
$630 For my God forks are
counts.
HR complaints, and who's screwing.
Who, and if you want to have false sloppy sex with me on Cyril's desk,
please line up art and take a number.
So just like any other workplace on TV, really,
except with far more weapons training and far less impulse control.
Uh, Pam, I will end you.
Well,
there is lots of high drama going on during each episode of Archer assassination
attempts, high-profile heist and countless deaths.
It is all treated with exactly the same casual disregard in mild irritation with
which your usual workplace TV characters confront conflict. As a result,
Archer gets to function like a typical workplace comedy.
Even if the workplace itself is a.
Yeah, but then I wouldn't get to hang out with everybody at work.
You hate everybody at work.
I know it's the only thing that gets me out of bed every morning.
Common in office works well for TV because of how naturally unchanging it is,
whether it's a traditional office like, well, the office or a failing bar,
like it's always sunny in Philadelphia or a police department like Brooklyn
nine, nine, the setting acts as a kind of bubble.
Fossilizing the characters over time,
the same people clock in at the same time each day,
make the same complaints about their job and get drawn into these same arguments
and flirtations with these same colleagues, all of this.
I've heard all of this before. No shepherd.
It makes the fictional workplace relatable.
While also letting the show reset itself. After each episode,
this repetition can also highlight just how psychologically stuck characters are
for Sterling.
This means drinking screwing and shooting himself into a state of emotional
numbness.
Every member of the team is the worst version of themselves on repeat Mallory,
manipulates everyone around her so that she can feel in control.
Cyril desperately tries to break free of his beta male image.
And lotta is forever caught between her revulsion and attraction to Archer.
Their inability to break with their own patterns,
both provides a constant source of comedy and makes them feel real.
Albeit hugely messed up. They are continually undone by the same weaknesses,
just like we all are. Of course,
we do see the characters managed to diverge from their well-worn paths from time
to time,
even if only a little Archer is willfully obtuse to the point that the vast
majority of his bad behavior never comes back to haunt him as a result.
He is highly resistant to learning any sort of lesson from anything.
No, I don't think it's a trap, although I never do.
And it very often is.
However,
every so often we catch a glimpse of the person hiding under Sterling's tough
facade.
Like when we learned about his troubled upbringing that left him emotionally
damaged and he has moments with Lana and Mallory would show that they do
genuinely care about each other, even if they never last them.
Just like I taught you without any help from whoever your father is.
Yeah, you were always there for me, which I never really thank you.
Archer's character is also rounded out with revelations about a sphere of
alligators or his attitude towards death. Bit by bit,
these little details combined with his constant willful disregard for his own
safety paint, a picture of someone who isn't just your standard cartoon sit-com,
but a guy who has a thoroughly and fascinatingly messed up relationship with his
own mortality.
Oh, so suddenly you don't have a death wish.
I've never had a death wish. It's just that.
I don't believe that I personally even can die.
With the employees of ISIS. It's these incremental bits of growth,
which give them their depth and make them more than just walking punchlines
rather than a random zaniness. Their jokes often play off their own psychology.
And history's pretty sure the Nazis had scientists.
That's why we very lost the war.
This kind of joke.
Laden character development is a prominent feature of other successful
long-running comedies. Like it's always sunny in Philadelphia. This is gay man.
That's two dudes bagging each other. I don't know where.
I fit in as a gay man and it's starting to get.
But despite the changes,
there is still a strong element of repetition for the whole Archer is marked
with these slow developments.
Pam steadily grows from the group's punching bag to one of its most formidable
agents.
Archer is continually forced to re-examine his relationships as new situations
emerge like when Lana reveals that she's pregnant.
A pregnant woman.
Or when Pam also turns out to be like the Palae of casual sex.
Well, how do you think that makes me feel? I don't care, Pam.
Now having said that,
would you please come in this dirty toilet stall and have sex with me?
First few seasons,
Archer had a firm grasp on how to drive the show forward in this way,
keeping the core dynamics largely intact while moving the pieces around just
enough to keep things interesting and being a cartoon,
it fell free to play a little fast and loose with the continuity flip-flopping
on certain changes. Ray was in and out of a wheelchair.
Cheryl was different kinds of crazy on different days, et cetera.
Even the introduction of the wee baby, Seamus legally, but not by a logically.
Archer son provided the perfect way for the show to flirt with the idea of daddy
Sterling,
without having to actually commit to it before giving him a child of his own.
A few seasons later.
Sterling Archer, I'd like you to meet your daughter
Aberdeen.
This flirtation is pretty standard.
The unwillingness to commit to any permanent changes often see sitcoms locked
in, never ending will they or won't they scenarios because these offer more
flexibility. For example,
if two characters actually couple up the show has to find a new,
funny direction to take them in.
So shows like Archer will largely flirt with consequences rather than see them
play out health scares like archers cancer battle will pop up and then quickly
go away.
Okay. So remember when you had cancer, um, uh,
vaguely.
Well office romances,
like his ongoing connection to Lana tend to find themselves endlessly in limbo.
And here's where things can start to go wrong at a certain point,
no matter how great the show, this can become stale.
As much as we like the comforting familiarity, we eventually get bored.
Archer is pretty explicitly aware of this problem with characters,
cracking meta jokes about their fear of things becoming too repetitive.
Most notably through the beloved phrasing Jones.
Are we not saying phrasing anymore? Guys,
we really need to talk about getting phrasing back in the rotation.
While other shows have tried to fend off the sense of staleness by introducing
new love interest or job changes.
Archer went all in and decided to shift settings entirely with Archer,
vice the show throughout the retro spy thriller template and went off on a
cocaine fueled.
Since the government has unjustly accused us of trees in,
we are now forced to transfer those skills from espionage to criminal activity,
kind of like the 18, but we sell drugs.
It proved to be something of a mixed bag.
The new setting allowed for the characters to evolve.
It all kinds of bizarre new directions like Pam's transformation into an
uncontrollable Coke theme.
And so from season five on Archer basically began an ongoing cycle of
radical change and reset the crew returns to being spies for awhile and then
gets busted by the U S government forcing them to shift gears again with the
coma seasons though is where things start to really go wrong.
Archer puts its faith completely injera hopping,
delving into Archer's unconscious mind as a way to transplant the show to a
different era entirely. And Hey,
is it all that different from the genre hopping?
The show is already done from hard-boiled in the ward zany space adventures.
Each new season saw the characters re-imagined to fit their new setting on
paper. This actually seems very smart.
What better way to counter sitcom boredom than by making each new season is
different as possible.
But what actually happens when Archer goes into a coma and the characters we
know and love go from 1940s LA to outer space, nothing great. To be honest,
the coma seasons basically detach all the characters from any sort of continuity
because these characters are just figments of Archer's imagination who look and
act like his colleagues watching out each character fits into the new setup,
provides lots of room for creativity and humor,
both in how they change and how they stay. The same.
Some characters are reimagined as monsters, animals,
and robots while Ciro remains a nebbish dork, no matter the context,
but everything that happens is also essentially inconsequential because for
three seasons, we know it will all be erased. When Archer wakes up,
this doesn't inherently make for bad television. In fact,
such an approach can really work.
The Soprano's famously used frequent dream sequences and even a pair of comatose
episodes and which Tony imagined himself in a completely different life,
much like our catatonic spy,
but these episodes worked because while nothing Tony saw was real,
they offered us a deeper look into his psyche and to add it to our understanding
of his journey through the real world, the moral of that story, basically,
if you're going to set a narrative,
so that is literally inside the protagonist head,
you need to have something to say about what's going on in there.
Don't get us wrong. Archers, dreamy seasons do achieve this at times,
keeping certain aspects of the show in place while everything else shifts around
underscores some of the shows, essential truths, for example,
no matter the time period or circumstance, Archer finds himself,
irresistibly drawn to Lana. And these moments,
the show tells us who the characters really are by showing us the parts of
themselves. They just can't seem to get away from.
And at times the more out there settings even provide interesting ways to
develop them. Like when Cheryl has sex with a literal doomsday device.
You may have some unhealthy associations with sex.
Yes, but again, it's Archer own psyche and not Cheryl's.
So who cares? What's more,
these insights are unfortunately few and far between for the most part,
the change of scenery just makes it easier for the show to retell all jokes,
resetting every character to a generic model,
which can be jammed into the new story,
allows them to repackage old gags like Krieger's creepiness and cereal.
[Inaudible].
It also sees the show tend towards a degree of [inaudible] with most of its cast
Flender is the process in which a character becomes increasingly defined by a
single trait, like how in the Simpsons Ned Flanders went from a gentle nature.
Do-gooder who happened to be religious to a full-blown religious zealot.
Everyone is beautiful. Yes, but Jesus said that pretty much the same thing.
Darn it. The Bible said the devil would be attractive.
Pam's years of hard won status and self-confidence are suddenly snapped back so
that you can return to being the go-to gross out punchline becoming a literal
monster during the gangs season in space,
by extracting them from any larger narrative.
The show quickly reduces its characters to little more than a series of
exaggerated quirks and overused catchphrases Archer.
And all of his friends are left, basically catatonic, still alive,
but frozen in place. The truth is that rather than solving the boredom,
which can seep in as a sit-com runs on for multiple seasons archers, wild genre,
jumping acted as a way of cheating or disguising,
the very problems it was trying to escape.
It frees the show from having to keep its characters in motion.
Interesting avenues like Archer's Parenthood or his attempts to be a faithful
partner are abandoned so that the show doesn't have to figure out what the hell
to do with him in this new context.
While the setting and genre might change the interior lives of the characters
remain totally static rather than solving the problem of sitcom stasis.
The coma seasons basically just dress it up in a different costume and hope the
viewer won't notice that nothing has actually changed,
but rest assured it's not all doom and gloom from the series somewhat
counter-intuitively. The show has managed to fight this DCIS by well,
taking a gigantically back to out.
Things used to be what happens is season 11 sees Archer awake from his
coma and ready to resume his role at ISIS. The spy agency,
which is somehow back in operation,
working out of the same old building with the same old staff as if nothing ever
happened almost as if miraculously saving us from the minor failures of the
previous three seasons,
this kind of hard reset might seem like an admission of defeat.
Like the band who realizes none of it's new material is working so agrees to
just play the hits from now on,
but it's already done a much better job at keeping the show fresh than the coma
seasons ever did while the surface details are the same as early seasons,
the deeper layers are vitally different Archer is forced to reintegrate himself
into a team that no longer really needs them. Cyril is now a super spine.
Lana is married and the whole agency is vastly more ethical, efficient,
and cost effective than it ever was when he was there.
I'm just going by the book and Archer,
a man pathologically in need of attention has to learn to live in a world that
he's not the center of. Even his favorite group. Jokes have gone out of fashion.
Whoa, sploosh, right? Oh yeah, we don't do that anymore.
You know what sploosh you have to sploosh you all sploosh.
Everybody's blue sheds. I do not speak.
These shifts in power dynamics create changes,
which are actually far more meaningful than any of the alternate setting seasons
could yield. And as a result, we see new sides to each character.
Cyril is an obsessively sculpted,
massive muscle built on a foundation of raging insecurity.
Jeezy Petes that keeps happening. The dangers of increased muscle mass, I guess.
Lotta has achieved this sort of peace companionship and professionalism in her
life that she always thought she wanted.
Pam who began as the hapless HRF has become a self-assured competent,
emotionally aware member of the team.
It's been three years numb, nuts.
We've had a whole thing going without you can't you just make an effort to fit
yourself in.
On that.
The show even manages to transform the ongoing anxiety about backsliding from
problem into a major theme. We must keep moving forward a Mediterranean,
which allows it to effectively self-analyze without disappearing up its own
completely. But what do you think wisecrack?
Did you enjoy the creative freedom that the comatose seasons provided or would
you rather see Archer keep his eyes open from now on let us know what you think
in the comments. Big.
Thanks to our patrons is always and try not to spill anything while you hit that
subscribe button, because of that is how you get ants. Also ring that bell.
It won't give you tonight us. And of course, thanks for watching.
Later.
[inaudible].